hey youtuber verse neil degrasse tyson
here star talk up next
cosmic queries planets and stuff
[Music]
this is star talk and i'm your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
and today is cosmic queries planet
edition
but we don't just stick to planets this
one is
planets and stuff
and today i've got paul mercuria with me
paul how are you
welcome back thank you damn near
irregular i
i please that's all i want to do no i
didn't call you irregular irregular did
i pronounce that
did you hear it actually i kind of am a
little bit but we can get into that
later i have a couple of questions about
how i can fix that but we'll deal with
that fix the irregularities exactly
uh great to have you on this yeah so
glad to be back and our normal format is
we
we solicit inquiries from our fan base
on different platforms
and the questions come in i haven't seen
them yet right this is not
stump neil day but it's if i don't know
the answer i'll say
next one please i've never seen you have
to say next week no usually i have
something to say about it even if i
don't
fully know the answer exactly just to
tell people
i did we first meet on uh at stephen
colbert we first met this cause
you're the warm-up guy yeah i warm up on
that show as a writer on the daily show
oh that go even further back oh yeah and
then the colbert report and i just came
to say i was a big fan once you were
very nice and then i came back the next
time i asked for a loan you said no
mr big shot doesn't have any extra money
okay
um and then you and then you were nice
enough to come on my podcast
which has still gotten like one of the
top listens just it's
really talks about it yeah we talked
about dark matter and all this other
stuff
and uh and then you asked me for money
for that and i'm like that's
inappropriate i don't have any money you
have them now
so yeah so we go back yeah yeah so it's
great it's great to have you and see
and and we are uh reporting now from
youtube new york city
in the google building yes this is cool
at the youtube production space
and so uh they're kind enough to so i i
miss all my books behind me maybe i can
have
like a plastic version of it just slide
it in you could you could have them
photoshopped in later
and it's right above the chelsea market
i got like a ham sandwich in my park
oh yeah yeah you can't walk through
without buying food i know exactly i
don't know why any skinny people exist
in this building that's not possible
there's actually a weight watchers
office here that's pretty weird
but yeah it's great to be here and it's
really cool space i didn't know this was
here yeah
and i always say and i'm going to say it
again if i had you as a science teacher
i'd be doing science today
really seriously i say that i don't i
don't yeah right carol i don't yeah
that's my wife
and uh because you make it accessible
your personality you clear it comes it
brims
you bring me with sort of you love it
and you explain what carl sagan said
he said when you're in love you have to
tell the world right i had
a eighth grade math teacher this bill
big hulking guy
he smoked in the class and he was like
and we made a battery like that was the
big thing like
right now you put the thing over there
it's like this like
he was like one step away from going off
track betting
and i just remember being intimidated by
him and i and
and i think people are very intuitive
from a young age and can sense if
somebody
cares or doesn't care oh yeah he did not
and that's why i think okay well thank
you though
yeah and just look at me i love you man
i love you man
it's not your fault
[Laughter]
just a little bit back at you um i
deeply respect
your profession the people who take
information in the world
shape reshape it hand it back to you in
a fresh perspective
and make you laugh at it these these are
very special mirrors
and i don't know how bearable society
would be without them
without the comedian who occasionally
shows up and said
do you realize this is what you've been
saying and oh my gosh
and right so this is why comedy is a
fundamental part of what we do on star
talk yeah well it's thank you i mean you
know
when i started on the daily show we were
just this little show and you know we
were just
doing jokes and didn't really say okay
we're going to have an impact on the
world
or whatever right and then things
started to happen
and we were always factually based in
our you know
in the comedic yeah sure so you have to
start with the premise so we were
delivering the news
with a non-biased point of view and just
saying does this seem a little strange
to you
so over time people come up to us and go
i only get my news from the daily show
well first of all we're a bunch of
idiots i don't think you should react
it's a paper so you said what the hell's
wrong with you
read a couple of newspapers but uh it
did end up becoming that and then you
know from that the uh the colbert report
the late show
or john oliver's show sam b show yeah
the whole the whole universe
yes is all sort of carrying that mantle
of
let's call people you know to the carpet
and so yeah so thanks yeah we it was a
nice byproduct of trying to have some
fun
yeah and we get in so much trouble too
because we would go too far with jokes
yeah yeah the president network we yell
at us but anyway we'll talk about that
another time
so what do you got for me your planet
questions i got some planet questions
all right very good ones and interesting
ones and
questions and answers i want to hear so
let's start with uh patreon
oh yeah i'm forgetting we do this yes he
says we're just kissing up to the
patreon yes
exactly ryan you are so handsome
that shirt you're wearing looks
fantastic on you
write a check um is it true that if one
had an
ocean large enough saturn would float
so this is often said
i've said it colleagues of mine have
said it
let me restate that in a more
scientifically precise way
okay all right because technically that
can't happen
all right you can't get a bathtub i'll
tell you one hell of a bathtub yeah but
how about i'll tell you why that
couldn't happen in a minute
so the scientifically precise way to
communicate that same information
is that the average density of saturn
is less than the density of water
and anything that whose density is less
than water will float
so saturn so the technical way to say it
is
if you scoop out a piece of saturn it
will float on a on
on a puddle of water or in an ocean it
doesn't matter so that's the way to say
it
it's more fun to say get an ocean or
bathtub big enough
saturn will float and i've said that
publicly lamenting that when i was a kid
i knew this was true about saturn
and all i ever had in the bathtub was a
rubber ducky and i really wanted a
rubber saturn
because so so later in my life we come
back to my office
someone mailed me a rubber saturn is
that right yes i now have a rubber
sander
and i can't i don't i want to leave it
in my office i'm going to take it home
to my bathtub
but um honey what's a rock doing in the
bathtub
it's a long story so i've got a rubber
saturn
so the problem is if you had a lake
bigger than saturn
to put saturn in the whole lake would
collapse into saturn
when the water just spill over onto the
shore when you put
when it displaced the water no no you're
thinking that they exist
independently of each other saturn will
pull
the bathtub into it and
it'll become part of saturn oh it's got
the suction power
unless well yeah it's called gravity
there's no such thing as gravity earth
sucks see that that's that's the old
joke
[Laughter]
so so so what was what was that
where was i oh so the problem is
you can't have a body of water bigger
than saturn that's flat
that you're going to put saturn in
because the body of water would become a
sphere and they collapse they fall into
each other
all right they each have mutual gravity
that they'll attract each other
so it's not a doable experiment but it
does get the point across
yes the saturn is lighter than water
plus saturn would need a life jacket in
case something happened
no that's what the ring is for oh god
i got you a network that's his little
life preserver
getting out of comedy now um
that's great yeah so it is in fact true
it is the only planet for which that is
true every other planet would sink
and it would absorb all the water and by
the way jupiter is very gaseous
and it's its density is close to that of
water but just a little bit above it
now how do we know this about saturn i
mean oh yes what you do
that's great do we go there and no so
you know how big it is
so what is density it's how much mass
you have
in the volume that you occupy so it's
literally mass
divided by volume okay grams per cubic
centimeter pounds per cubic
inch that's density those are the the
units of density
so we know the size of saturn and we
know the mass of saturn
we can measure it from its gravity and
other things you divide those two
numbers
you get a number that's less than one
and that means
in the right units and the density of
water is one
yeah by definition basically yeah okay
yeah
so we know yeah it'll float all right
and um uh here's something i figured out
about myself just a couple of weeks ago
i was swimming a couple of weeks ago and
i was floating more easily than ever i
have in my life
but you did have a lot of hair you
needed a haircut yeah no
no i'm just a little chubbier than i was
when i was younger because fat floats
and muscle sinks that's the thing it's
about the density how much mass are you
packing into a volume
so why do you think you can say how much
does a whale weigh
well a whale weighs nothing it's it's
it's neutrally buoyant floating
swimming in the water you have to ask
how much mass does it have
it's why the biggest animals that ever
existed
exist in the water they don't have to
hold up their own weight against
the gravity uh on earth's surface the
whale
is the biggest creature that ever
existed in the history of life on earth
and yet it can float because its density
is about the same as water if you are
less than water
it would have to use energy to stay
under under water because the water want
to make it float
which just happens to human beings well
if you're real if you're chubbier you
will
your body will float okay will float
very well and you'll take energy to go
down below
if you are more dense than water you
will sink to the bottom and it'll take
energy
to stay afloat if you're about the same
density as water
you can move through the water with no
you know like the
the ease of a trapeze or whatever that
line goes in the song
so so following up on that
here's something interesting ready you
know the smartest person in the world
was you raising your hand no
one of the most clever people in the
world was the first person to figure out
you can build a ship and everything you
make the ship out of
is denser than water and it can float
you can you can build a ship out of
steel
and have it float that does blow me away
when it doesn't work this is just
changed it changed warfare
and was it a specific scenario shane
what paul you got can you pause on that
sentence please
it changed warfare you don't have to
build your boat
out of wood right which is susceptible
to cannonball fire right you can build
it out of steel
right how do you get it to float
because the part of the boat that sits
below
water is mostly air
the hull of the ship sits below
water so so what matters is not that
steel is heavier than water and air is
lighter than water it's
what is the average density of that
which you have
plunked in the water it's the total
volume divided by the total mass
it has less mass than you think because
most of it is air
an aircraft carrier most of its volume
is air
so it's able to flow because of the debt
really the relation of density of the
water correct
correct anything that's floating has is
less dense than water on average
period and do you think that that was by
mistake about a byproduct of something
else that somebody figured out steel can
float
no they were making canoes out of wood
because wood floats and why would you
make it out of anything else right
but then the steel the next step was
steel in order for it to float it has to
have a significant amount of volume
underwater so that the air can represent
this right
okay so so the larger the vessel
the deeper the hole for the most
generally it's not going to just be
skimming
right it's going to sink in right it's
going to respond to that
the fact that there is steel there yeah
and then it'll come down to the level
that's just right
right for what the weight is if you look
at container ships
they have these lines painted on the
side of the hull depending on how much
gross weight it's carrying so the more
weight it's carrying
okay the heavier the thing is
the total density goes up and it's going
to sink a little lower into the water
got it yeah and they they know when that
they reach their max capacity
so ice is denser than cork
so that's counter-intuitive to in
looking at ice versus cork
well cork is from a tree so you know
it'll flow but it's less dense
because ice evidence of that is the cork
will float almost entirely above the
water
right there's hardly anything sunk below
it that's true whereas
ice 90 of it is below the water um
which is why you have icebergs that's
why you have the iceberg problem
yeah wow and james cameron in titanic he
did it right
okay did he when they hit they basically
when they hit the iceberg
it's this little thing in the water it's
just it's a little thing
sticking out of this it's just little
things 90 of it is underwater
right that's what cut up the side of the
hull right oh my gosh
whereas in the first titanic movie
the black and white 1940s whatever
there's this huge iceberg out there oh
my gosh
okay then it has a hand that reaches out
and cuts it it's got a knife and a knife
it's like west side story on the ocean
once a jedi
so so if you do the physics right you
don't need a big iceberg and in fact
this is contributed to why was
one of them several reasons why it was
so hard to notice
it was it's actually small dark it was
doctor wasn't any moon right
it wasn't foggy but it was right here
somebody was watching youtube on their
phone
we're going to move on that's fanta
that's fantastic my favorite
anachronistic quote
is um a quote from abraham lincoln where
he said
never trust anything you see on the
internet
it's a meme it's so beautiful it's just
you just gotta you gotta love it yeah
you gotta love it and coming from him
yeah
yeah he's got a lot of credibility on it
yeah he does
you know i'll give it to you it's a man
that knew what the hell he was talking
about yeah the stove pipe
yeah questionable choice there but uh
then a buckle on a hat
yeah what are the play what what if
pilgrims need a buckle and a hat he
wasn't
out there excuse me this is 200 years
later would you get your time period i
understand he's a top hat without a
buckle but
but this is why my brain goes this way
answer that question smartypants
why do you need a buckle on a hat
somebody letting their head out well no
you can squeeze it down in case the wind
blows it tightens up on your
with the wind and the density and the
volume and the whale oh i taught you too
much
you've created the mess the student has
become the master
all right you're gonna eat that cookie
later i gave you right well i i got a
quick one since we're talking about hat
brims
um do you know the size of your own hat
that you wear
i have a p head p like p brain p head
i'm like seven and a half small i have a
small hand seven half would not be a
small hat
that's a large hat yeah don't don't
argue with me about it so you got a fat
head if that's if that's your actual no
no no
no no no no no no no no three six and
then it's probably six and a half six it
could be
so here's your head here's i have a fat
head yeah so here's the building that's
really what it is ahead
so so i don't know if you knew this but
that hat size
has mathematical significance okay
please tell me it's not in relation to
my you know what no it's not
not that i know that you know what i
know what you said you know what
so here's what you do you take a tape
measure and measure the circumference
of your head okay write down that number
divide it by pi that's your hat size
oh yeah i just thought it was that no no
no it oh you got to divide yeah if
you're if the circumference of your head
is six and a half inches
you know you're not you're some other
species you're a rhesus monkey i don't
know
but yeah well my wife would agree with
you about some other species
you don't want to see me with my clothes
off it's really pretty um
uh i said okay well i just learned
another thing because i just thought
what my head size was literally like you
just made it measure no no no no you
must have never really put those two
numbers together
so i was in a hat shop because i always
wanted to own a top hat that you can pop
into oh yeah i always wanted someone and
they make hats so i they measure my fat
head
and they wrote it down and say we need
you need a size eight or something so i
said fine do you know where you get this
number he said he didn't know
i told him he said really really yeah so
we did it and it
said i'm glad that he was skeptical so
then you can do the experiment we did it
on his head
and his assistant's head it all came out
it was all perfect
and so he wanted me to write it out so i
wrote it out and i signed it and it's on
the wall of his hat shop
yes yes though with the pie and then you
imagine him going home now
honey how was work well this dude came
in and we did math problems all day
but i sold a 400 hat so i guess it was a
good day
that's so awesome you signed it it's on
his wall it's on
it's on the wall that's better than like
a diner that gets you to sign a picture
i know
yeah yeah no why picture me what i
didn't know you want to put something
that can advance
you human understanding it came from
your giant ghoulish head
oh now ghoulish is part of an adjective
this is my last time doing the show by
the way
um okay we ran out of time to do a
second question in this segment
so when we come back we will continue
with
star talk cosmic queries planet edition
hey you're all fans of space and science
and many of you are creative
if you're looking to make a video about
space exploration story blocks
has all the stock footage you could ever
want with their unlimited video plan
you even get nasa archival footage
i mean it's got the hubble and the space
shuttle
and apollo 10 footage and this eye
that turns into space it even has
freaking neil
armstrong storyblocks also has templates
like this to make it look like you
actually know how to make your broadcast
quality animated graphics
check out the link in the description to
learn more about storyblocks video
that's storyblocks.com star talk
space the final frontier
we're back cosmic queries second segment
of three paul mercurio always good to
have you what did you tweet at what
uh at palm curia one arm my last name
m-e-c-u-r-i-o yeah
okay so good there were no other paul
mercurios in the two well i had to
change the spelling of my name because
it's
no joke there's an australian actor paul
mercurio
and he got in the actors union before i
did
oh so you can't have the same name still
that's why you're
the first r in my name so mercurial yeah
yeah people still think i'm him
sometimes
he's hosting a reality beer show in
australia that's the thing
okay so yeah he makes like craft beer
and so like every couple craft or crap
no no what what i missed the last no
there's an app in there crafts
yeah okay and uh i get every two weeks
or so i get beer recipes from people
thinking i'm him
okay and i'm like okay that's happy so
anyway at home curio
all right i think go for it robert
weaver also patreon
good uh thanks very much for continuing
to educate and inspire us
what news and science do you find the
most interesting or
important is it the private space race
no i know too much about the private
space race for that to be uniquely
interesting to me
things that interest me are things i
know little about and
so that i want to know more about i love
watching the progress of neuroscience i
think the brain
our inner universe in its attempt to
contemplate
the outer universe presents one of the
greatest
intellectual challenges of our modern
times and
where what advancements are we making
right now
that either surprised you or my view of
the field
which is a very unpopular view among
psychologists
is that the day will come when i'm
hypothesizing this that the day will
come where we understand the
neurosynaptic
phenomena in the brain with such
precision
that no one will ever have to lay down
on a couch and spend an hour
with a psychologist because i do that
and seriously and like i there's a lot
of stuff i got to figure out and work
out
right and some of it so maybe there's
let me tell you about my mother so
so there may be things where people just
need someone to talk to
that's one thing but if you have some
trauma or some
issue that you can't shake or some
addiction
you can't overcome i'm imagining there's
a day we'll find the exact spot of the
brain that's responsible for it and what
would that prevents you from
pushing that next glass of high ball
away from you or to go into depression
or whatever it might be
depression especially depression where
or
anything else that lands you in one of
these one of these
funky states or the one of these
hospitals in these mental hospitals so
that's the spot that's misfired what are
we doing to the spot are we going in
are you creating are we taking a
medication at this point who knows is it
too much firing or is it not firing
enough or does another have
it has to be another path into it that
connects to this other brain center
that helps modulate it i don't know okay
i'm imagining
that a future will arrive where we have
that much knowledge and control
of what's going on in the brain so that
you can just nip and tuck
and fix all of these problems and why
wouldn't psychologists welcome this
theory dude because they'd all go out of
business overnight
it because you don't go into anybody's
office for an hour and talk to them for
not usually not for an hour for a whole
suite of sessions that could go on for
years that gets resolved in an afternoon
i think my psychologist is making up a
lot of stuff i think i'm fine
i really do and i think that what do you
mean it's not just the whole community
there's counselors and and psychologists
psychiatrists
this sort of thing we're kind of almost
there there's a lot of depression that
is
not cured but addressed by medication
all right we know what chemicals will
leave you in a depressed state which
ones don't
and why is it the production of those
chemicals well let's go in
adjust your your genome or your
neurosynaptic
um drivers in such a way that you're
producing your own chemicals so you
don't need the pill
right because the problem with some of
these pills is there's this sort of
whack-a-mole you fix one problem and
then there's
sort of you know by-product symptoms of
problems correct because the pill
gets ingested and it goes into your
whole system right whereas if you
surgically go in
to one part of the brain for one so now
what one of the challenges to that
future
is the brain is highly interconnected to
itself
okay so
an ability expressed in one part of the
brain some of that
is also in other parts of the brain
which is how you can compensate
for some brain injuries not
compartmentalized it's not as
compartmentalized as we'd want it to be
for it to be a nice clean thing right
right right right right
and while we're on the subject did you
see the movie
what's the one with scarlett johansson
and sure she
oh she's her brain power has increased
yeah is it lucy
i think it's lucy lucy yeah so
the pr the entire premise of that film
is that she
takes some drug turns out by accident
but
it it boosts her brain power not to
something she didn't or any of us don't
already have
it just enabled her to access the 90
of the brain that you're not using okay
well where did this whole premise come
from and by the way the whole scenes in
this film
of rooms full of psychologists studying
her as a phenomenon
okay it comes from some guy a hundred
years ago or so
i forgot his name forgive me who through
brain injuries and other aspects of
because you can't just go and start
poking around in someone's brain
you can't you sound like you have been
yeah i gotta stop that cross that one
off my lips i got a guy in my basement i
got a guy
i gotta probably let him go now all
right yeah so
you what he said was what he published
was the brain is so complex
we know only what ten percent of it is
used for
but how is excuse me that became
we only use ten percent of our brain but
how do how do we know he's right it's a
theory
no no no you're you're in the wrong room
right now
all right i'll leave that no no what
he's no i'm done
i can't work like this
there is in the youtube music space
it doesn't matter whether or not he's
accurate and he probably was accurate he
said well there's a there's a
language center here and there's another
all he said was
we only the brain is so complex we only
know
what 10 what 10 percent of it is used
for
that's all he said a completely innocent
comment
we have much more to learn about the
brain
it got re-quoted as
we only use ten percent of our brain oh
this is my point you know you weren't
paying attention to what happened
okay if you think we
use only 10 of your brain this is the
mantra for teachers
with students it's a very hard
thing to correct right when saying it
incorrectly is what you want to hear why
do you think we want to hear that
because we want to believe that we all
have potential we can grow into
okay here's the underachieving student
you're just using 10 percent keep
working on what and
using more of your brain you have vastly
more potential right
we're into potentiality right right
especially in america
okay now i'm going to teach you how to
tie your shoe again and you're six
and seven years old or whatever you've
got okay you can do more so that then
became the premise of this entire movie
she's now using 40 of her brain she's
now using 60
and at 80 percent she's like flying
through
web pages learning whole dictionaries in
a matter of minutes
and she's even changing her hair color
with her brain and starts doing
telekinetically which is weird like why
should a smarter person be able to move
things
with their mind that's not an obvious
next step
maybe the object feels intimidated by
the brain power and it just wants to get
out it just seems to me you solve
problems faster that's all
smarter people don't have telekinetic
powers yeah
right that's really true right and all
the movies did this
i am so smart toaster come to me
[Laughter]
there's no one that's not a thing
i went to i was in best buy the other
day and there was a guy making tvs fly
it was crazy
he was a really smart guy so but with
all of our abilities
so i'm intrigued by that branch of
science that's what started the question
so a hundred years ago 100 years is a
long time
why haven't we been able to get to know
more than 10 percent of the vein brain
12 percent
20 it's hard to study the thing
that is giving you the thoughts to study
the thing
oh it's very it's very recursive right
it blew my mind
man you want to hear another recursive
recursion
is very mind-blowing you ready yeah
cause i recently got a word into the
oxford english dictionary
yeah yeah the manhattan henge was in
there this is
first used by neil tyson in 2003. i said
what took you so long
16 years later but i'll take it wait
what's the word manhattan henge
you know manhattan hence oh those are
two days of the year where the sunset
aligns on the manhattan grid
and now thousands of people flood the
streets blocking traffic it's a great
oh my gosh think about all the other
reasons traffic had been blocked
you know there's an accident or
construction or con ed is digging
you know new york's electric company but
now we stop it for the universe
i'm loving it uh so anyway so get a word
so here's you ready
every word in the oxford english
dictionary used to define
every word is also in the oxford english
dictionary
okay so if i look up a definition of
something all the words they assemble
to define that word are themselves
each one of those is in the oxford
english so it's not possible to have a
word
in there that is not in the dictionary
but is indeed a word
because then that's why it would be in
the dictionary defined but how do we
know that they have it covered
we don't but what we do know we're not
even being funny there you know what i
mean like
you gotta we don't but we know
that they haven't covered better than
anyone else it is their singular mission
in life
to record every use of every word
but you're biased you got a word in
there you're gonna you're gonna kiss
their rear end all day
oh you're so smart the oxford dictionary
i didn't say they succeeded this i'm
saying this is their mission statement
to have every usage of every word
ever in the english language
so if a word first appears they have the
first appearance of that word
if you use that word slightly
differently pivoting its definition
that usage is then given you pivot it
again it's good
there it is and this gets back to the
point about the brain because the brain
we can get
only to ten percent because the the
thoughts that you need it sets
no no forget the ten percent it's it was
misinformation from the very beginning
i understand that but when i asked about
well why can't with all this well it's
one of the challenges
how do you study the thing that's right
that is the thing that's studying the
thing
right a b you can't just sit there and
operate on people for scientific
experiments you know
paul i want to know how you think so can
i remove your top part of your skull
and put electrodes in your brain just
for my science experiment how much would
you give me
did you take over my mortgage i would
add
very happily have you open up my skull
my tiny skull
size six and a half we got it again
exactly what
uh another question there's a follow-up
to this which i think is a follow-up
why doesn't the matter in saturn's rings
accumulate like the matter
in a uh proto-planetary disk
oh i know the answer to this because it
gets cleaned once a week by a guy with a
shop vac
anyway yeah no that's another so the
matter saturn's rings are very thin
and they're small particles and they're
very thin and the matter
does collect it collects into certain
zones
clearing out other zones so in fact
saturn's rings have
gaps in them which you kind of see
you can see with a medium power backyard
telescope
and in fact there's there it's not just
simply you can see
like the the ball of saturn through that
gap when it's at the right angle
so you know there are no particles there
or at least very few so they collect not
in a sphere
but they collect orbitally all right
because they have
stable orbits around saturn
and they're not much mass there to begin
with they're not going to
overcome this orbit and then coalesce
into one
moon for example when our moon was
created we had a ring
that whole ring collapsed into a moon
because of huge chunks
of material that were there whose
gravity wins
and it's the it's winner takes all if
you have slightly more gravity than this
other
object you will attract slightly more
material than this will and those larger
objects and what was the ring around the
moon came from just sort of
oh no earth had a collision earth we
were sideswiped by
another planet right and our earth's
crust
got spewed into orbit around us into a
ring and that ring then coalesced into
the moon
and so so there you have it so one of
the most depressing things i learned
because i'm not an orbital dynamicist so
i'm reading some papers from
some colleagues was to learn that
saturn's ring system
might just be temporary why well because
they track the orbits and the orbits are
not stable that they they're you're
losing them down into
saturn itself yeah yeah yeah yeah suck
that's the second time i'm using this
word sucked is that
it's gravity is pulling them in bring a
new sentence to you
wait a minute sucks why because sucks
not in the oxford dictionary is that
right
uh so and and when do they anticipate
when
that might happen that those rings
disappear well so they suspected that
it's a 10 million year or so life span
which would mean the dinosaurs if they
had telescopes
saturn would not have rings for them
they were 60 million years ago
they were longer ago than saturn's rings
would have yeah so the ring's about i
feel sad
yeah i'm just saying i'm going to miss
those rings
those times we had together in 10 10
million years
okay next question okay here we go um
this is from
uh carcella
bonaciour i'm sorry if i'm butchering
that twit
this is from twitter uh since jupiter is
90 hydrogen
can we tell it's a failed star if it's a
spell so
ooh yes we can tell if it's a failed
star but you won't learn that until
after this break
wow see what i did there was that good
that's how the pros do it right right
okay when we come back we will find out
whether jupiter was a failed star on
star talk
are you obsessed with planets do you
want to look at beautiful footage and
animation of foreign worlds
with story blocks and their unlimited
video plan you have access to an entire
universe of 4k
footage there's jupiter earth like
planets
uranus that's right you heard me uranus
not uranus artsy stuff and so much
more they even have pluto and obviously
i'm talking about the dog because
there's no reason to talk about pluto
when you're not talking about the dog
because you wouldn't be talking about
pluto
if you were actually talking about
planet right
create like a pro with the newest
highest quality content
sourced from a select group of artists
that storyblocks partners with
check out the link in the description to
learn more about storyblocks video
that's storyblocks.com
starttalk we're back
cosmic queries planets and stuff
paul we last left off yes yes we had a
very interesting question from twitter
uh and this is from saracella bainsuru
uh since jupiter is 90 hydrogen can we
tell if it's a failed
star so she knows that the sun is 90
hydrogen
so these big gaseous things out there
basically
have their birthday elements in it oh
the universe is birthday elements 90
of the universe is hydrogen ninety
percent of the atoms of the universe
are hydrogen atoms about eight percent
are helium atoms
when you see that ratio in big gaseous
things they're mostly made of stuff the
universe was born with
so if stars are made of 90 gas and
jupiter is could jupiter been a failed
star
sort of why because it was on dancing
with the stars
is that where all the veil started uh
does that joke still have currency
people still talk about that
people who career they need a boost they
go on dances with stars
yeah okay um i'm asked all the time to
be on dancers with stars
you have to go no i'll tell you why not
i want to see you in tights in the mass
and the volume
you want to check out my density that's
what you're saying but i remember
talking about this on my podcast you
danced professionally a cemetery you're
like a trained dancer when you're
i was in a performing member of three
dance companies but they were like
college troops they were not
it was not the [ __ ] once you got it
you got it
but that was a chapter of my life long
gone okay i'm not thinking of my present
and future and saying gee
i should dance again this is these are
not my thoughts
when i was dancing i was not writing
books no one was publishing my essays
okay so paul
take kindly the council of the years
gracefully surrendering the things of
youth
i think you should dance after all that
i just told you
that's the best you could just listen to
what i tell you to do please
so you have a uh
possibly a failed star oh sorry that
that's what we were talking about
thank you so so jupiter
had it been i forgot the latest numbers
on this
had it been maybe five times
more massive somewhere around between 5
and 10
it would have been a star and we would
have had a double star system
why does that size suddenly make it
because the
bigger you are the higher the pressure
is in your core
because there's more mass there's more
weight
there's more pressure and when you have
pressure in the core
the temperature rises and as the
temperature rises there's a threshold
where you start fusing
nuclei in the presence of heat
thermo nuclear fusion
that's where you get that word from the
sun is undergoing thermonuclear fusion
in its core
the high pressures high temperatures are
squeezing together hydrogen atoms and
out the other side comes helium atoms
and the helium atom has less mass than
the hydrogen atom
where did the mass go e equals m c
squared it became energy
and that energy is sustaining the star
jupiter didn't have enough
didn't cut didn't didn't hit that
threshold and forgive me if this sounds
like a silly question and i'm being
serious
if it's if jupiter is 90 hydrogen yes
is it just this ball of gas could i fly
through it or would i
hit yeah so so there's no surface right
so you fly straight into it
and you just keep plunging down but you
start feeling higher and higher gas
pressure
above you and eventually you get
squashed or vaporized depending on
whether you hit a hot zone
sooner than a high pressure zone so it
depends on
how how resistant to pressure you are
that could get you to deeper
if you have a vessel for example they
could get you to deeper places
where it's even hotter so it did so
jupiter did get hot in its core
oh don't let let's not be unclear about
this
it did get hot it just didn't get hot
enough to hit that threshold
of thermonuclear fusion it would have
been fun to have two suns though
in our in our solar system what would
that have been like for us
bad a lot of sunscreen
as you go around the suns you're you're
closer to one at one point and then not
so close to the other that can wreak
havoc on your
the stability of your climate also it
wreaks havoc on the stability of your
orbit
who where's your orbital allegiance
today relative to yesterday
never good for orbits you your orbits go
unstable and you fall into one of the
two stars or you get flung out
i say that all the time it's never good
for two orbits i mean
but you know never good for orbits uh
next question next question
okay uh this is uh ulysses
lindblad uh twitter do you get
high and low tide on the northern and
southern poles
oh very good question
you know i never thought about that so
let me think about it now for the first
time
and i'm thinking no because the bulge
well excuse me you wouldn't definitely
wouldn't
in the first day of spring and first day
of fall
because on those two days the poles are
sideways to earth and the tidal bulge
is a bulge of the of the ocean the of
the
the water mass of the earth in a tidal
bulge it bulges both
towards the moon and away from the moon
so it bulges in both directions
okay this way this way correct that's
why there are two high tides in a day
all right do you even have you ever know
do you ever oh yeah i know it's like
we have we go boating you go boating
yeah there's two high tides in the day
why why
i don't know because it has two bulges
one so here's the moon off to the side
there's a bulge that's closest to the
moon and it builds its opposite the moon
so you say well if the moon is tugging
on it how could it bulbs the other way
here's what's happening the moon is
tugging on the water
and on the earth so it's tugging the
closest water gets pulled the most
which makes low tide only on the sides
of this because the water got
sucked out of the intermediate places on
earth
so the point that points towards the
moon that's closest it feels the moon's
gravity the greatest
then it's earth that feels it next
greatest then there's the side of the
water on the other side of the earth
that feels at the least so there's an
elongation
of the entire system in the direction of
the moon
and that's these are called tidal forces
tidal stretching of
earth has tidal goes through tides
they're not as high as the water
but earth the solid mass of earth
actually stretches
in this way as earth turns once a day it
goes through two high tides
now these bulges come out from one side
of the earth and the other
okay so the size of your tides
are affected by several things but also
sort of your latitude yes
on earth i'm expecting that the equator
will have higher
range between high and low tides than
other latitudes would
but there are other factors that affect
it do you know the highest
swinging tides is the bay of fundy why
oh bay of fundy because there's a long
is it a fjord
it's a very long track
of land that two sides of the land that
that has a long
um i think it's a fjord i mean and
so what happens is it's the tide comes
in
and it's that the slope is very shallow
so if the tide goes up a foot it goes in
a half a mile
it's really cool so you can like run
alongside the tide
as the tide is coming in because it's so
shallow it's so shallow and so the tide
when it goes up a foot it's going to go
up a foot but if to go up a foot make
sure you have to go
down shore a mile that's where it's
going to be
when it raises when it goes up a foot so
the movement of these tides creates
friction against
between the waters and the earth and the
height of the tide i think is not so
important in that case
as much as how much the tide moves and
how much friction
earth feels against it and you know this
friction
between the oceans and the tides is
slowing down earth's rotation
we're in the stuffed part of this
forecast
why is it slowing down the rotation
because earth oh
i left something out this tidal bodes
that i set aligns with the moon
it doesn't don't lie to me man
don't play i have to lie to begin the
explanation otherwise there's two
it's tmi okay do we understand what i
just told you that the moon
stretches this whole system first of all
stop yelling at me okay
i'm just kidding um yes and can i just
say it quickly from my own
so we're on the east coast the atlantic
ocean so when
and we're in new york city so when we're
a lot when uh
when this side of the earth that we're
on is sort of aligned with the moon
that's when you're going to get low tide
because it's pulling if we're aligned
with the moon
it pulls it and we're going to get a
high tide i'm sorry he's pulling it
right okay okay okay
now you want to know something
interesting when you're at the beach we
say oh the tide's coming in tide's going
out
that's not what's happening the tide is
just always there
in space you're on the solid earth and
you're
rotating through the high
and low tides so if i picked a spot in
the ocean
the tide is always that level no not a
spot in the ocean you pick a spot
in line between earth and the moon pick
that spot
that'll always be ocean water at a
certain height
they'll just be there and so and earth
that whole system and earth is
earth the solid earth is rotating in
that
and so when we're in it it feels like
high tide when we're in it we say
it's tied coming in and out but it's
earth rotating
into a high tide bulge and out of a high
tide bulge
wow yeah where does this pretty cool
display
but so so it's the illusion that
something is coming towards us and away
from us it is you are rotating into it
and so now
i said it lines with the moon it doesn't
it's ahead of the moon
and why is that because earth is
dragging the tide
this whole bulge wants to align with the
moon but earth is not letting it
it's pulling it in front so that so so
the tidal bulge
is a head of the moon it's gravitational
cool right uh
it's see i didn't use the word suck no
no it's the friction between earth and
all of this water
that is shoving the water ahead of where
the moon is
and the moon is trying to resist this by
pulling come back to me
tide no i'm pulling it ahead of you this
battle between earth and the moon
is slowing down earth's rotation
it is the source of the occasional leap
second
that is thrown into the calendar because
it's
slowed down by this process because the
moon is making the tides and the tides
are resisting
what earth is trying to do and what
would earth be like if that
did not happen if we didn't have tides
if we if the
this if it didn't get slowed down by
this friction that's happening
uh if we didn't get slow down then the
duration of a day
would be stable but it's not the length
of the day is increasing
very slowly but you're not going to
notice it and you're not going to care
but clocks care
gps satellites care those that matters
but a day isn't 20 every day isn't 24
hours no not anymore
it's slightly longer than 24 hours and
rather than increase the length of a
second
which would create its own problems we
just say wait till that increase
accumulates a second then we just throw
one in
that's so on the leap second years
this last minute of that year has 61
seconds in it
just to make up for things because of
the tides
because we are dragging ourselves
through high tides and low tides in
space
that this explains why i'm always late
they're tired
thank you i got to the bottom oh did we
only get through four questions
give me one a quick one quick okay i
think we've actually run out of time
okay let's try i'll give a soundbite
answer ready give it to me okay uh
this is from uh tropicaltroy68 instagram
hello there guys i love the show can you
tell me
what u.s taxpayers gain by going to the
moon six times
uh from 1969 to 1972 other than a bag of
rocks
hold me back hold me back
i i'll give you another question no i
said i was only going to give a sound
bite answer here it is you ready
so i could speak on this for an hour
but i won't i'm going to speak on it for
one minute
when we went to the moon to explore the
moon
and turn around and photograph earth
we discovered earth for the first time
all major environmental legislation that
exists in this country
is traceable to the years that we
were landing on the moon we went to the
moon to explore the moon and we
discovered earth
oh my gosh earth not as your schoolroom
globe
showed it to you no not with color-coded
countries
no earth as the universe intended you to
see it
with oceans and land and clouds
and we're all down there together
it is the greatest of the gifts of the
cosmic perspective
that we have ever received only when the
photo of earth from the moon was
published she would say hey
wait a minute maybe we should ban leaded
gas maybe we should ban ddt
maybe we should clean up the earth maybe
we should clean up the water supply
maybe we should clean up the air maybe
we should protect species
there were some versions of those acts
that existed earlier
but the comprehensive version where
everybody's behind them that all
happened
1969 70 71 and 72
the environmental protection agency was
founded in 1970
we're still going to the moon so i ask
you
what is the universe and the cosmic
perspective it provides
worth to you
i am intrigued and frightened at the
same time
it's such a pain to fill your videos
with engaging visuals
especially if you're like star talk with
a small crew
making an engaging video is a
non-starter unless you have story blocks
let's say you want to produce a video
about making cookies oh yeah
cookies you'd have to film everything on
your own hire a camera operator get in
the car
drive to the store sit in traffic find
your ingredients pay for everything go
back home preheat the oven
measure the ingredients mix them
together wait for them to cook
wait for them to cool and finally you
can film yourself
eating some delicious cookies or you can
do what we did for this commercial
you just use story blocks for all your
footage needs with their unlimited plan
you get all the 4k footage you can eat
the content is royalty free for
commercial and personal use
so you can put it on your youtube or
just about anywhere else
check out the link in the description to
learn more about storyblocks video
that's storyblocks.com slash
star talk god i'm hungry
i've been your host neil degrasse tyson
paul mercurio
co-host thanks for being on dude
absolutely uh as always until next time
i bid you
to keep looking